Oh everyone
I think parallax is getting loose see I
don't care about this random planets
destruction if it's not earth I have a
hard time getting emotionally involved
in an exploding planet Alderaan didn't
affect me and I don't even know if there
was life on this planet here no one who
watches the skies for living notices
this still photograph of water staining
in for frozen water is still
photographed in case you confused it
with Giza at Puerto Rico he was in Japan
just a second ago and now the Silver
Surfer will continue his random journey
over worldwide famous landmarks I see
roland emmerich got his hands on this
thing somehow in case she confused it
with los angeles jamaica also bloody
hell now los angeles considering this
trip was going west from japan to egypt
i guess the rest of the united states
had no silver surfer sightings now the
powers going out in LA but doesn't
freeze over like the last two places he
flew over absolutely no one is playing
on the field at dodger stadium but the
people came anyway main characters first
appearance time perfectly to a nearby
television news program talking about
them VidCon girls Reed still wants to
marry sue despite her freak alien
eyeballs also seriously what the fuck
happened to her eyes dude you are not
here you were over posing with the hot
girls that you would never in a million
years stop flirting with to go sit in a
chair and do nothing
dr. Richards I'm very sorry but it seems
we're overbooked American Airlines we do
have some seats available and coach
though an airline would never force
celebrities of this caliber out of
first-class some other asshole is gonna
be flying coach also this is clearly a
setup to a hilarious the thing has to
sit in the middle seat joke sorry Ben
must have sat on the chick who had the
window seat because I don't see her
anymore that's a tragedy disguised at a
comedy in my book Reed Richards is a
dick to people in general
scientists ruled out global warming as
the cause of the extraordinary climatic
events Oh Fox why were we subjected to
that five-minute airplane scene were
they flying away from a much better
movie that we didn't get to see six
minutes and 30 seconds in and yes you
are still seeing credits on screen movie
with no story directed by a guy named
story the city is trying to charge us
for three squad cars they say we destroy
the city allows the Fantastic Four to
fight crime but only if they pay the
bills for the damage they caused showed
up just in time for the sequel
view movie rubber fingers do not equal
superfast fingers
you cannot just flash up your non speedy
characters yeah sue says I'm addicted to
it to moving your fingers really fast
because I'm pretty sure that's not
exactly what you meant but I could make
hay with that kind of setup they're
being caused by cosmic radiation not
unlike the kind which gave us our powers
I'll let Johnny take this one wow that's
really boring a bachelor party could be
fun but no exotic dancers Oh a bachelor
party does not contain a lap dance ha ha
Latveria yeah you get that plot kick
started movie is there anything I can
help you with yes what happened to your
eyes
also they dragged poor Andre Braugher
into this didn't they movie creates
convoluted overly sexy scenario so that
the hero's love interest will totally
get the wrong idea and we can have some
generic conflict rubber neo number three
oh wait I got confused with all the
fakeness the military just absolutely
needed to show up unannounced looking
for Reed during his bachelor party
didn't they a simple phone call out of
the question
we're concerned that these anomalies
might pose a credible threat to our
national security
have you tried searching the horizon for
bright lights traveling at high speeds
either freezing or am peeing everything
in it's weak that might be where I'd
start do you have anyone watching the
sky anyone at all
you've never seen anything like it you
mean balls of light in space also I see
people who watch the sky for a living or
watching the sky and noting the
incredibly rare unexplainable phenomenon
it's just taking days for that to
translate into the military asking the
superheroes for help gotcha surprise
revealed that Von Doom escaped the
shipping container prison from the last
movie is not a surprise Susie doesn't
know anything about it I don't know how
Reed expects to build this giant thing
out in the open without sue knowing but
hooray for conflict don't tell Johnny Oh
Johnny what nope he didn't even come
close to hearing that this article
refers to sue is the luckiest girl in
the world I actually think they meant to
write read and if they didn't change the
pronoun that would be fine by me
so what's it take to take the Human
Torch fireproof lingerie a lot of
ha ha Moo be afraid of first base keeps
making jokes about third and fourth base
Stanley is playing the actual Stanley
here
what means he's attending the real life
wedding of characters he actually helped
create in the comic book universe and if
that doesn't just blow Stanley's mind I
don't know what will it just doesn't
feel right I know I'm blind but want the
Gabba to your eyes this had between
Kerry Washington and Jessica Alba is
good but I know what would make it
better just linking it to my PDA this is
where reid officially becomes kind of
like a bad guy right he lines to his
future wife who is Jessica Alba he's
distracted by this project instead of
Jessica Alba he's willing to let this
thing update him during the wedding to
Jessica Alba Adele he'd wake up one
morning and find out she was killed in a
rock slide semen joke is semen Jesus how
much emergency gear did von doom have
hidden away throughout the world before
his capture and escaped zoom and enhance
cliche we interrupt this fantastic for
sequel to bring you the Return of the
Jedi
rise of the Silver Surfer that's a
sequels name and the wedding is wearing
it out dead superheroes have dead
parents cliche cosmic radiation just
happens to be detected in New York so
Reed doesn't seem like such a bad guy
after all
ah that is cool boobie decides to
fellate itself after one decent visual
effect okay guys if you want to take the
Lincoln Tunnel that's cool but you know
that goes to Jersey right also pretty
sure Johnny just charbroiled a dozen
innocent civilians right there meanwhile
in Washington I could just kill him
right now
but I'll let gravity decide this we
interrupt this Fantastic Four movie to
bring you the flying hero crashes in the
desert sequence from Iron Man and that's
not even mentioning the ripoff of the
flying heroes flying abilities in
question while falling only to return
just in the nick of time thing also from
Iron Man Silver Surfer character design
and advertently inspires Prometheus also
Andy Serkis isn't playing the Silver
Surfer in this movie evidently this
entity this Silver Surfer roll credits
this is cute but it's also legally
torture in most states and spousal abuse
in most others everyone in this scene
gets a look at naked Jessica Alba except
the audience also movie makes exchange
of power as possible so that Sue's
clones can burn off and they tease naked
Jessica Alba for the fourth time in two
movies
why does this always happen to me this
wasn't even in the script it was just
Jessica Alba complaining to the
producers I got an idea boss what if
they all change powers brilliant write a
script around that we start shooting in
two days
Johnny's always been more of a solo act
here's another movie trying to get away
with the conflict by eavesdropping the
Johnny you've given us throughout these
movies would just storm right into the
room and start bitching these two out
few movie Vaughn dune contract the
Silver Surfer without the use of Reed's
satellite but apparently no one else can
for some reason so Johnny merely tried
to talk to the Silver Surfer and the
surfer tried to kill him Von Doom shoots
lightning at the surfer and the surfer
just tosses him out of the way and call
ourselves what the dynamic duo and
Marvel really has an inferiority complex
to be constantly named checking Superman
and Batman also DC Comics guys we've got
a serious problem we've got a serious
problem cliche everywhere the surfer
goes eight days later the planet dies so
Bieber then also to remember how wrong
gear calculations were in the first
movie and recalculate that means you
have about sixteen hours maybe twelve so
the next in the sequence should be and
nothing important happened at all during
the time it took them to fly from New
York to London next time there's no next
time that's why I'm bringing in some
help general Hager contradicts himself
by telling Reed there won't be a next
time but then basically saying well
there is a next time but it'll be with
Victor Von Doom you're gonna put
innocent people in danger know more than
you already have Hager told Von Doom I
want you to hide somewhere when I tell
Reed I'm bringing in help he'll protest
and that's your cue to come in
you trust Victor and you're gonna regret
it so far the only one I've regretted
trusting here is you but I'm still
letting you help me for some reason look
at where the energy levels surge when he
attacks me general Hager has already
seen this right that's why he allowed
Von Doom into this operation so why the
focus information not share with Reed
before they went out to London rock star
level famous superheroes are alternately
mobbed in public and left alone entirely
depending on the needs of the script
she's very attractive with the you know
that's very sister
how's it going didn't sue also go to MIT
as a tremendous scientific brain either
she can help Ari doesn't want her to
help why he basically Pepper Potts in
this movie it's gonna be alright you
know it won't be well I think we have
room for one or two more cliches in this
thing don't you got lying around over
there got any hero gets anxiety issues
about pressure related to the job I can
I feel your pulse slowing down do you
remember that time a pulse man thank God
sue casually said the word pulse who
attack yump off you need something that
moves faster than the speed of light to
throw the Silver Surfer off his board if
you can generate tachyons you better
build a time machine or some and not
forget about it in the next movie don't
wait and you activate the field it'll
separate him from his board oh well you
make it sound easy I've seen as a guy
that I almost got his team killed Top
Gun script somehow made it into the
Fantastic Four sequel this is not a game
everyone's been saying like this to
Johnny but only the hot girl gets
through to him because the power of
boners is stronger the other side that's
why I flew you and the rest of your team
to Germany so that you could just press
a button also what was this scene about
the military felt the need to tell
Johnny they were gonna interrupt the
surfer so he could tag along but not
actually use him in any meaningful way
so let me make it clear for you and you
pack of freaks if we interrupt this
Fantastic Four movie to bring you the
mutants are outcasts vibe from the x-men
movies but I guess who never played
football in high school
suddenly movie feels the need to lay out
a dick-measuring contest between Reed
and Hagar as if Hagar has been that kind
of adversary the whole movie I stayed in
and studied like a good little nerd and
15 years later I'm one of the greatest
minds of the 21st century instead of
getting some other Lackey you could
position these tachyon pulse generator
things around the Fantastic Four have to
do it themselves ensuring that Von Doom
will go on watch during this entire
operation so this is Germany there
aren't any bears in Germany I mean in
2006 there was this Bruno bear that had
to be killed but he was the first one to
be seen in 170 years sooo pleased that
we have a problem game so that Reed has
to ask what the hell she's talking about
still for surfer crashed into some
random spot in the Black Forest but doom
knew where he would land we're now in
Siberia and the mission is over but yeah
let's keep the Fantastic Four on our
trip to Siberia to where is he I'm very
serious
I took my hair out of a ponytail for
this fortunately pursue Von Doom
requests a meeting and the general calls
for a break just as she's trying to have
a private conversation with the surfer
wouldn't her voice be enough is there
any reason to become visible again also
none of the video cameras in this
facility apparently captured this
conversation they're all pointed at the
Fantastic Four not the prisoner in who
is the one I serve who do you serve
surfer please the pronoun game so that
sue has to ask who the hell he serves oh
come
I mean the guy has been rendered
powerless by his board but he still has
a documentary video to show on his
washboard abs Galactus the Devourer of
worlds so parallax then this movie is
fast becoming a discount Green Lantern
and I'm sure I don't have to tell you
what that means my surface spares my
world and the one I love ah last-minute
villain turned hero love story this guy
is Bane Miranda Tate is just around the
corner somewhere why did you try to
protect me you better not say what I
think because you remind me of her ah it
is not I who draws the destroyer here it
is the beacon the source of my power
so as board draws the destroyer here and
the Destroyers basically gonna eat the
planet my question is why does the
Silver Surfer need to go around cutting
holes in the earth for weeks before the
destroyer comes can he just eat the
planet without the holes also he never
got to finish the one he was gonna do in
Germany so if it is required the
destroyer is gonna be missing the full
complement of holes he needs to eat the
planet okay so is Saturn dead now
even if earth survives this that'll be a
tragedy for about a week would Pluto try
and reinstate four planet status you can
do your ptosis on the board let's go do
that right now I mean it's not like I
was in the middle of an interrogation or
anything Wow Viktor somehow built a
wrist pad that controls the alien
surfboard I'm not even mad
that's incredible Reid's had a special
Fantastic Four jet this entire movie but
never thought it would come in handy
until just at this moment
pammi you will never find a more
wretched hive of region ducing product
placement than this movie we're now
officially enemies of the United States
of America
Viktor it's out there somewhere with
unlimited power will you the narrator I
was once called
mmm exotic you know I've never been the
giving type breathe
the Fantastic Four all have ear buds but
how the far they able to hear victors
calm speaking voice at 500 miles per
hour in the sky movie rips off the ship
splits into smaller ships thing from
Star Trek The Next Generation and fly a
few miles from Siberia and boom Wall of
China just like that motherfucker's also
Victor is a dick to seventh wonders a
lactis went from Saturn to Earth in like
ten minutes but then takes forever to go
from the edge of Earth's atmosphere to
actually destroying earth I mean look at
how fast he's approaching Earth in this
fucking shot did you take all of 1015
seconds for this thing to begin and end
this whole movie Jonny's glitch has been
causing them to swamp powers he gets a
new power of someone he touches and they
get his then at the finale
Johnny can somehow get all four powers
at once because Stanley
I know HBO is fucked in all this mess
shoplifting then climbs this one crane
but thankfully the battle between flying
superheroes and intergalactic planet
eaters never strays far from that one
city block so Ben can still have an
impact on things
so he's electrocuted right that's all
for von doom once he lands in the water
right obviously not really dead
superhero is obviously not really dead
surfer ex machina answer me this why
would a planet eating space monster put
in his employee an indentured servant
and given the power source capable of
overthrowing the monster if the surfer
is this powerful then why the fuck did
he ever allow himself to be the slave
and let his planet and girlfriend be
threatened surfer ex machina duo
films beat conflict resolves itself if
it wasn't for the team the whole world
will be gone by now
I know it's amazing how comic book
villains start showing up on earth right
after comic-book heroes get their powers
let this be a lesson men
if a woman constantly tells you she's
not interested it does not mean she's
not interested wait and Sue Storm Venice
is sinking into the Adriatic and you
have your PDA set up to inform you of
Venice's whereabouts yeah that's cute
but Venice is sinking into the Adriatic
Sea assholes
poor bastards thought they were gonna
get a third movie
a bachelor party could be fun but no
exotic dancers
[Music]
you guys um we use a large vibrating egg
aggressive feelings boy
[Music]
Oh guess what day it is why are you
destroying our planet you think that's
air you're breathing now this is not a
game we're talking about practice not a
game not a game not a game not so tough
now are you everybody that reads comic
books knows that Kirby Silver Surfer is
the only true Silver Surfer now am i
right or wrong what's your name all
right you got a question what is your
favorite cut